so i think it's fair to say that a lot
of people including myself to a certain
extent
have been pretty relieved at the fact
that chris chibnall
is leaving his position as showrunner of
doctor who
however we're now a week out from that
announcement
and we don't know who's taking over for
him yet
should we be worried about that
[Music]
hey there folks so i want to kind of
talk about something that i am actually
a little embarrassed was a little bit of
an oversight on my part
when i did the video last week talking
about the departure of chris chibnall
and jody whitaker from doctor who as
show runner
and the actor portraying the doctor
respectively
i talked about a number of things and i
laid out a timeline of how these things
usually go down in terms of
announcements of future doctors what i
didn't check and i wish i had
but i didn't so now we're following up
what i didn't check at the time
was what the timeline usually is for
announcements of new showrunners
because to recap quickly what i laid out
in that previous video you can see the
whole thing there if you haven't already
but what i laid out for that specific
thing was basically the timeline
of from when david tennant announced his
departure going through
matt smith you know being announced when
david tennant actually left the part
when smith came in and then the same
thing for smith the capaldi to
whitaker and through that it seems very
clear to me that there would be no
um indication or reason to believe that
we will get an announcement on our next
doctor until
series 13 airs because that's been the
pattern new doctors are announced
regardless of when a actor is announced
to have be leaving the part
the actual new doctor gets announced
after the last
full proper series that the outgoing
doctor gets but before whatever specials
are being given
to let that actor sign out the part
completely
that is when these things happen
but what about new showrunner
announcements
how long after the initial announcement
that the old showrunner is leaving
and who the new showrunner is what's the
time frame on that
how long is it usually now we've had
fewer
showrunner turnovers then we have doctor
turnovers so
while i can still point to a pattern
there's only two data points as opposed
to
um three or four um in the case of the
doctors because it's
kind of hard to count out because then
things were weird but anyways back to
the original question how long
is that time gap usually there isn't one
up to this point the next showrunner
has been announced at the same time
sometimes in the same press release
that announces the departure of the
outgoing showrunner
so that's already different from the
outgoing doctor which has a gap
so the fact that we are now a week away
from chibnall
being announced as leaving and we don't
have a successor
what does that mean now
first thing to realize i do not have an
inside source
i don't have knowledge that no one else
has on this so everything i'm going to
be saying
is based off my own deduction my
understanding of the industry and
looking at what i consider to be the
most likely causes or reasons or
outcomes to all this
some people can and probably already
have spoken with a lot more
definitiveness about some of these
things i'm
not going to do that i'll talk about
what i think is or isn't
likely but i don't know for certain no
one does and if they claim
they do then they're either lying to you
or they're kidding themselves
so what does it mean
that there's a gap when there's never
been one before
well most likely the literal thing that
it means
is no one has been locked in as
the new showrunner yet does that mean
they don't have one
no not necessarily but there is a
period of contract negotiations figuring
out how long these contracts are for
working out schedules etc
and all of this stuff has to be signed
off and locked in
before you start announcing stuff
because announcing stuff before you've
got
pen signed to paper that's how you get
things like
universal announcing the dark universe
and how there was totally gonna be
a frankenstein movie starring harvey or
bardem and they were gonna have angelina
jolie be the bride of frankenstein and
johnny depp was gonna be
the invisible man when nobody had signed
anything they had indicated like yeah
sure if
these things move forward i'm interested
but like nobody was locked and none of
those movies happened
so and bbc itself has had its own issues
with this even within doctor who
of the many things that appear to have
gone on to and again i'm
gonna try not to get into this too much
that have gone on that appeared to
rub christopher eccleston the wrong way
about working on doctor who
one of them and one of the ones we knew
about the earliest in terms of being an
issue
was the bbc announced his departure
early then was agreed upon by
eccleston so he felt betrayed by them so
you really
need to be sure you're on the same page
of whoever it is you're going to be
announcing either incoming or outgoing
so again the point in that whole ramble
is just because it hasn't been announced
doesn't mean that there isn't
one basically locked in but we're
waiting for ink to dry on contracts
that's a possibility
it's also possible that they don't have
a next showrunner locked in
so the question then becomes if that is
the case
so again i'm not saying it is i'm not
saying
because it's distinctly possible that
they have one
basically locked but contracts aren't
finalized
each day that goes by that we don't have
an announcement makes that one
less likely because it shouldn't take
too
long so then that brings us to
what if they don't have a replacement
candidate yet
okay so if that is the case why would
that be the case
well there's a couple of possibilities
the first possibility
is that they have not whittled down
a final determination from a pool of
candidates
that may be because perhaps their top
choice has a schedule that isn't quite
as accommodating and they're
and there's debate at the bbc as to well
do we shift around the schedule of a
show that has had its schedule shift
around a lot lately and it has not done
anything to help
its standing or ratings do we shift it
around even more to accommodate our
preference do we go with a second choice
who maybe is available right away so
those kinds of things could be stalling
a final decision
it's possible that the bbc is still
sorting through
pitches of what new show runners want to
do
i don't really have the inside knowledge
to know
how much detail show runners had to give
to the bbc in terms of laying out in
advance what they wanted to do
with the show however i wouldn't be
exceptionally surprised if they asked
for something like that
following chibnall even if it wasn't
standard up to this point or even
through chibnall
if only because a lot of its decisions
were divisive
and if the bbc is afraid of more
super divisive decisions maybe they are
doing a bit more vetting
on either the showrunners themselves or
the ideas that the showrunners say the
potential showrunners said it say that
they want to do
so that's a possibility i've seen some
people float the idea that they are
going that the bbc actually intends to
put the show
on hiatus following the exit of
um whitaker and chibnall
i that's the one i think is the least
likely that one makes the least sense to
me
because if they are actually planning to
do that
from the get-go there really is no
reason not to just say that
now because they're not going to do
themselves
or the show the property any benefit by
stringing it out and making it seem like
there will be more when there isn't
going to be
if it was a if it's a planned hiatus
it doesn't make a lot of sense to not
tell us
it's pretty standard practice of any
and television entertainment company to
say
hey we here's the plan for the next
season
or in the case of a show like this with
specials next season and a bit
and that will close out the show that
will be the end
you tell people that it at the time so
that they can basically
know what they're coming into and kind
of get
emotionally prepared it's a bit of a
courtesy thing but also it's one less
thing to potentially leak later and
i don't pay too much attention to the
supposed leaks
i i just don't i don't have an inch and
that's not unique to the bbc
i have little interest in leaks because
they turn out to be correct so
infrequently that i don't just i don't
like sinking my thinking time
or my emotional involvement in on leaks
i just don't like doing it
it's a waste most of the time but
the fewer things you are holding as
secrets the fewer
issues leaks are going to be so again
if they're gonna put it on hiatus and
they delay that announcement it's
gonna leak at some point so they'd be
better announcing it now
so i don't think a hiatus is the thing
that is planned here
another reason i don't think that is no
matter what you think
of the chibnall era and no matter what
anybody says
about the ratings and where they
currently sit at and or what the ratings
for series 13 are or whatever else
doctor who is too valuable a property
for the bbc just to close down because
you need to realize
doctor who is bigger than just the
ratings that it gets in the uk
which is generally the only ratings
being tracked because
this is a big deal
for the partners of the bbc they license
out doctor who
it's one of their bigger properties to
do that when hbo max was first announced
one of the crown jewels that was
announced as something that they
acquired and would be airing that wasn't
a holy in-house production was doctor
who
so this is a big deal as is
the merchandise the spin-offs you know
big fit i mean big finish is an
independent company um and isn't owned
by the bbc but
these things fueling that fire and
continuing to fuel it is in the bbc's
best interest and i think they know that
so that's another reason i don't see a
hiatus being planned or at least not a
high-end this of any more than
a year two tops but even that i don't
think that is what they would want to do
so the question then becomes is the
issue that
they can't find a showrunner at all
either they can't find a candidate that
they're happy with
or the ones they want don't want to do
it
and there are many potential reasons why
that might be the case
again certain channels and certain
pundits let's go with that term are
going to be quick to say no one's going
to
want to come in here and deal with the
mess that chibnall created
i don't think that's the case i think
for
any creators including ones who have
worked on doctor who previously
who don't want to come in and be the
showrunner there are a
litany of reasons why they might not
want to do that and i don't think that
accounts for any of them there is
something linked to that that might
account for it but i'm going to save
that
for last so it might be
they've got their own projects they want
to focus on their own truly original
ideas that they would rather be working
on promoting
if they haven't worked on doctor who for
a long time maybe they don't have ideas
to
do on doctor who some of the writers who
i have really enjoyed
their work on doctor who who i've seen
floated as potential showrunners
folks like toby whitehouse paul cornell
jamie matheson
they haven't written on for a varying
degree of years
you know some longer than others maybe
that's because they haven't been asked
maybe that's because they just don't
feel like writing in that world and
that's not to say they don't still like
doctor who you can like something and
not
feel like writing it right now so it
could be that
it could be if like i mentioned earlier
if the bbc is
putting more oversight on the show that
i had before which again purely
speculative on my part but if that is
happening
maybe they don't feel like working under
those conditions and
somewhat linked to the chivnalera thing
i would not rule out the possibility
that some otherwise viable candidates
might be saying no because they don't
want to deal with the [ __ ]
show of angry fans right now
because let's not pretend that this
began and ended with chibnall it got
worse with chibnall
but fans were really ripping into moffat
too and honestly i've been a fan of this
thing long enough that i remember people
ripping into
davies towards the end of his run
now the scale and scope of it has
absolutely changed but i've said before
i when i first got into this show which
was
i started watching it airing yeah at the
time new episodes came out
with series four i was on
doctor who message boards where i saw
people tearing davies apart with a lot
of the kinds of stuff that
well people complain about chibnall like
he's the first one to do it complaining
about
the insertions of what they call
diversity characters or political issues
etc etc so like
i and i've said this before with other
topics this stuff has always been there
but the amplification has gotten bigger
it got
bigger with moffitt and as
the sort of volume
and i don't mean volume as in amount i
mean just loudness
of people being driven by
certain people on platforms like youtube
and twitter
who drum up anger
as part of their brand as that really
pushes harder and harder and harder it
gets
louder and it gets more frustrating to
deal with one has to imagine and as i
said
you could see that volume getting turned
up on moffitt
as his time went on i would say really
kind of starting to crank up
during capaldi's era it wasn't there a
little in
smith it started getting bad during
capaldi's era and then chibnall has been
full
force now again this is not me saying
that you are required to like
those eras the moffett era the chimneal
era or that you have to like every
episode or every decision
creative that those people made you
don't
i'm just saying the people who are being
the harshest
who are calling for the harshest things
who are saying the
cruelest most
indefensible things at
the people responsible for the show they
have gotten
louder i don't honestly think there's
more of them than there used to be
but they have gotten louder and they've
gotten organized
which amplifies those voices more and i
would not blame
any creator even if they love doctor who
even if they
think they've got a great idea for
doctor who i would not blame any creator
who looks at this nonsense and not even
just with doctor who who looks at stuff
like what happened with the new star
wars trilogy who looks at
all the vitriol thrown at the creators
at the actors and at multiple of them
like people love to crap on ryan johnson
but then
rise of skywalker came out and nobody
liked that and now jj abrams is a huge
villain too whereas before he was seen
as
the good guy who made a good movie that
john's the script like
this vitriol knows no bounds and it can
and will hit
anybody i don't blame anyone who looks
at that and goes
no no i i don't
uh i don't want to deal with that
especially knowing that
certain stripes of fandom are going to
call them
cowards who don't listen to fans because
they don't address
bad faith arguments
it would not be an easy job in a vacuum
where social media doesn't exist
but social media does exist and it is
weaponized
these days by certain elements of fandom
and that is not something that you could
just pretend doesn't exist
it may impact some people some creators
some writers actors etc
harsher than others either depending on
that own person's ability to
cope or how much crap gets piled onto
them because i'm sorry
everyone has their limits
and it would be hard to look at what's
gone on with doctor who and doctor who
fandom and not go
me taking up this job is gonna put a
target on my
back and i don't really want it
so all this
being taken into account all of these
possible factors or possible
reasons should we be worried
about the fact that we don't have a new
showrunner announced
not yet but i would say
every week that goes by that we don't
have an announcement of a new showrunner
that gives me pause
and it makes me nervous and again i
don't think there's a planned hiatus i
have a hard time
understanding why that would make any
sense
but we might find ourselves
in a hiatus by default
because creators
are busy don't feel like
dealing with the fandom don't want to
play in this particular universe right
now
who knows but the longer the delay goes
on
the more it starts to feel like is there
nobody who's qualified who wants
the job
i don't know maybe hopefully not
like ultimately i hope that the first
thing i said is the reality that
they've got someone they just need to
lock stuff down and
finalize it or like they've got it down
to like two or three people and they're
just trying to sort out
exactly who whose schedule lines up best
or who had the best pitch or whatever
that's what i hope because and i always
say this whenever i talk about the
future of doctor who
i want this show to go on forever
there is never reasons to stop it there
is never a reason to reboot it
i would argue that at most maybe a
a breather of a little bit but there is
no reason to stop
the show is built to revitalize itself
and it can do that at a regular interval
and i will always always want the show
to continue
and i will always hope for the best for
it from the performers
from the writers the directors everyone
i love this show and even when i don't
like specific episodes or series or arcs
or creative decisions
i'm going to keep coming back because
i want it to be good and i want to enjoy
it
and it has yet to do anything for me
at least that has made me go i need to
walk away
is it impossible for it to do that no
but it hasn't happened yet and i don't
intend to
i love this show i wanted to keep going
and i want what's best for it
i just need to know who's steering this
ship
if anybody so there's my thoughts on the
delay in the current situation with the
lack of a newly announced showrunner for
doctor who
what are your thoughts on this be civil
please
to me to chibnall to anyone else who you
think might take this job
and even to other youtubers i know i
threw a little shade
a little bit but no personal attacks in
the comments i will delete your comment
and if it's bad enough
i'll just block you from being able to
comment just don't do it
don't be a jerk and i'll try not to be
but if you can keep it simple whatever
your thoughts are drop them down in the
comments let's talk about it
i have a patreon which is what pays my
bills enables me to do this
as my job any amount you're able to
support is a great help
don't worry about it though because like
share subscribe also helps me out a
great deal if you're not able to support
me financially
but even those things i'm not going to
pressure you too much because
at the end of the day you are the
council
i'm just running the meetings so until
next time this council
is adjourned
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
so
[Music]
um
[Music]